hisbah the Shia militant group backed by
Iran and based in Lebanon has been
exchanging fire across its border with
Israel what is hisbah and how great a
threat does it
[Music]
pose when Lebanon gained independence
from France in
1943 political power was divided among
the religious sects in proportion to
their size with the three largest groups
getting the most
power but the influx of displaced
Palestinians into Lebanon in
1948 increased the Sunni Muslim
population sparking sectarian tensions
that led in 1973 to a 15-year Civil
War during this period Israel sent
troops into Lebanon to try to crush
Palestinian militias that were carrying
out crossb
raids it was during the Israeli OCC
occupation of part of Lebanon that
hisbah or the party of God in Arabic
emerged Iran seeing an opportunity to
expand its influence in the region began
funding and training young Shia
militants to harass Israeli troops in
Lebanon by the mid 1980s hisbah was a
powerful organization backed by Iran and
Syria it published a Manifesto which
promised to fight Israel and the west
and advocated for an Islam
regime at the end of the Civil War in
1990 hisbah and its Allies won 12 of 128
parliamentary seats in
elections the group helped Force Israel
out of Lebanon in 2000 winning it
political clout since 2005 it's held
seats in the Lebanese cabinet and in
2009 it updated its Manifesto calling
for True democracy rather than the
establishment of an Islamic
state hisbah is an important force in
the region Iran supplies it with weapons
and it maintains good relations with
Syria over the past two decades it has
periodically fired rockets and launched
raids into Northern
Israel in 2006 hisbah went to war with
Israel in response to Israel's ground
operation in
Gaza there's speculation it might do the
same
again since hisbah has an estimated
150,000 rockets and missiles
any decision to join the current
conflict could lead to Serious
escalation